[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
we shouldn't be here when it gets dark
set the trap of the mouth of the cave
please
i am a doctor
ah it's impressive don't you think
vampire bats weigh almost nothing but
they can down a creature nearly 10 times
their size
wow
what are you using this bait
you volunteering
leaving
pay me now
before the sun goes down
you throwing that bushcrafter on your
belt and we have a deal
[Music]
[Music]
what are the keys
[Music]
everyone's here to help you
michael
this is lucien lucien michael michael
knows more about this place than i do
hello hello milo
my name's lucian
the person who was here before was milo
no
he was also the new milo
before him was the other new milo
i don't even remember the first milo
how long have you been here
as long as i can remember
and you're still not cured
there's no cure
there's something missing from our dna
like a piece of a puzzle
and until they find it the only way to
stay alive is an oil change three times
a day
what would you do
if you could be normal
just for an hour
i don't think about it
best not to be outside when school gets
out
like the original spartans
we are the few
against the many
[Music]
milo
milo
nurse
lotion
lucian
with one of these
it took a team of scientists to build
that machine and you fixed it with a
ballpoint pen
there's a school for gifted children in
new york
i think that i could get them to agree
to cover your tuition
and provide private care to help manage
your condition
somewhere you could study learn hone
your skills
knew the gift michael
i don't think i could forgive myself if
i saw it go to waste
dear milo
this isn't goodbye
i'm gonna find a cure for us
so we can be cranky old men someday
your friend michael
p.s you shouldn't have unfolded this now
you'll never get it back together
see you this summer
please can i have my letter back okay
[Music]
please
[Applause]
all
stop stop stop stop
what about milo
i look after milo
he needs me
[Music]
you